many count Christopher Nolan's 2006
Thriller the prestige as one of his
finest films and nothing gets fans going
like a sequel so why have we never seen
The Prestige 2.
let's start with the most obvious reason
why the prestige 2 hasn't happened yet
Christopher Nolan simply hasn't
expressed any intention to make a sequel
even if he wanted to it doesn't seem
like Nolan has the time he couldn't
release any kind of sequel right after
the release of the original because he
had his hands full with his Dark Knight
trilogy even after he finished up in
Gotham Nolan found plenty of other
projects that he presumably found more
interesting Nolan has also expressed
interest in doing a James Bond film so
he might prioritize that over a sequel
to The Prestige meanwhile some fans
speculated after Oppenheimer Nolan could
attempt to return to a previously
unfinished project a remake of the 1967
show The Prisoner which Nolan was
briefly attached to direct in 2009
others predict he might continue his
trend of historical films such as
Dunkirk and Oppenheimer however a sequel
to The Prestige is at least a remote
possibility
that said there's still a chance that
Nolan could return to the world of The
Prestige Even after spending more than
15 years working on other films Nolan
seems to prefer taking a break to work
on something else before returning to
director sequel thus what happened with
his Dark Knight trilogy after moving
away from Batman to direct Inception
Nolan came back for the Dark Knight
Rises later admitting to Entertainment
Weekly that the break left him
invigorated and excited to return to
Gotham City speak of the devil
and this shall appear it's worth noting
that the prestige actually originated as
a small scale project that no one wanted
to film in between Batman movies after
releasing Batman Begins Nolan shared
that he was open to doing a sequel but
added that it wasn't His Highest
priority in 2005 he told black film well
I definitely intend to do something else
first I want to do something smaller
after having done such a big film now
that Nolan has spent over 10 years
creating epic Standalone films he might
be more willing to come back to The
Prestige of course Nolan's sentiments
might also have changed since then in a
later interview with hitflix he said I
tend to think that if you have the
chance to do a big film you should do it
while you can I'm always worried maybe I
won't be able to do a big film again
well there's still some hope that the
prestige 2 might one day come about you
probably shouldn't hold your breath
judging by how the first movie ended
producing a sequel would come with some
inherent challenges especially if it
were to live up to the original for
while in the absence of Hugh Jackman's
Angier would make filming a sequel quite
difficult the Rivalry between Borden and
Angie sit at the heart of the prestige
yet with angia presumed dead any sequel
would be missing that key element and
while the existence of all those clones
could give Nolan a good excuse to bring
him back it wouldn't be easy to do this
without seeming contrived Nolan could
also create a new character to face off
against Borden virtue Jackman left some
pretty big shoes to fill in that regard
here's another problem we already know
exactly how angia and Borden perform
their magic tricks the ending of The
Prestige already revealed these
magicians deepest Secrets which doesn't
leave much to explore in the sequel
while it's possible that the prestige 2
could in Earth more of Borden's secret
or introduce a new character with their
own it would be difficult to top the
reveal at the end of The Prestige like
any good magic trick a story is less
interesting to watch when you already
know know how it's all pulled off
since nobody has announced a sequel to
The Prestige there's been no news from
Christian Bale on whether or not he
would return his Borden we do however
know how Bale feels about returning as
Batman which suggests that we might
respond to a potential Prestige too when
asked by comicbook.com if you would be
willing to star in a fourth Batman movie
Bale said if Christopher Nolan ever
decided to do it again and if he chose
to come my way again then yeah I would
consider it so attracts that he would
most likely be interested in playing
Borden again so long as Nolan is
directing since Michael Kane is another
frequent Nolan collaborator it's likely
that he would be game to a prizes for
oldest cutter Scarlett Johansson
probably wouldn't need much convincing
to return either she once described The
Prestige as one of the most beautiful
scripts she has ever read absolutely
perfect and I thought I had you know I
have to do this project I had I wanted
to do it so badly likewise Hugh Jackman
loved the prestige so much that he urged
his own production company to study
Nolan's crew as a model no doubt it'd be
thrilled to return as Robert angia if he
were needed
When developing The Prestige Nolan
begged David Bowie to accept the part of
Nikola Tesla he later told Entertainment
Weekly I told him if he didn't agree to
do the part I had no idea where I would
go from there now it's impossible to
imagine the film without Bowie and a
sequel arguably wouldn't feel complete
without Tesla either alas he will not
get to see him portray Tesla again since
Bowie died in 2016. still Nolan might
figure out a way to create a sequel even
without Bowie's presence after all Nolan
managed to write a fitting conclusion to
Batman's story without the Joker and
without making his absence obvious
speaking about the fact that the Joker
is barely mentioned in the Dark Knight
Rises Nolan told Empire and that is
something I felt very strongly about in
terms of my relationship with Heath and
the experience I went through with him
on the Dark Knight I didn't want to do
in any way try and account for a real
life tragedy that seemed inappropriate
to me so if Nolan does ever decide to
make the prestige too it seems unlikely
that Tesla will have any part to play
even off screen
if the prestige 2 ever comes to fruition
there are countless possible storylines
it could explore at the end of The
Prestige we saw Alfred Borden reuniting
with his daughter and presumably
retiring from the stage but the sequel
could well follow Borden as he would
turn so the magician's lifestyle once
more if Angie isn't coming back at all
another character from the first movie
could easily step up to play an
antagonistic role who better to cross
salted Borden than his former assistant
Olivia she knows most of his tricks
after all meanwhile Borden's Obsession
might lead him to all but abandon his
daughter Jess who would now be a
teenager or maybe the hopes to train her
as his assistant and eventual successor
there are so many paths of prestige
sequel could tread basically Anything
Could Happen